okay this is the honey I would make
yesterday we looked at an exorcist again
super super broad overview tone they
always said basically about an excess
system was was what do we say yeah
that's that's here basically I've got an
expert experience wisdom insight and we
just want to try and mimic that in
electronic form as closely as we can
that's as far as we go okay so today
we're going to have a look at some of
the nuts and bolts right so it's like
let's do a bit of the car and looking
out of the fun bits and pieces and
actually see how they interrelate
function so number one there are four
main components of an expert system okay
for that we're interested in any way
that actually defined the way operate as
your essential that there is a fifth one
but it's slightly different to the other
four and not quite as affordable alright
so what are the four big component the
first thing is what we call they are
knowledge base I'm gonna abbreviate that
to KB after that there's something very
similar but you'll see the distinction
is something called a data base on fans
guide basic facts you like knowledge
base database they are both databases
okay well I'm going to try and
distinguish between - oh okay I family
you have what's called an inference
engine inference the word inference has
you my project
okay like what you make inferences just
try to understand why something causes
something else okay and lastly this is
one two three
fourthly you've got a fourth an
explanation mechanism as a really
awkward actually all of these four
things have four canoes but as you see
them they're not that complex hey I hope
you double see how all of these run
parallel to our human expert but what
they're able to do right so let's start
we want to know come on
the art of a goldfish now what this is
is a set of rules basically okay
generally there are kid destitute leak
down statements if their statements are
the kind of things you were creating in
spreadsheets very simple if a certain
condition is met okay then carry out
some other kind of action right so rules
here I think like okay if the
temperature is below 50 degrees will you
leave the house then where you jump out
as well as you play because that's
pretty cold now this is logic there's
these kinds of rules I got from
experience that's why we use an expert
knowledge we try and condense it into
these kinds of rules or statements now
there's a there's a whole job associated
with taking what a human thinks and
those and converting it into this
language like a translation problem
right
and the person who's dropped that is
correct knowledge engineer or a ke
well they engineer so their job is to
talk to someone the domain expert you
know it's always been a doctor for a
long time someone who's an expert of
firefighter and understanding three
patents in weather and see what happens
to a buyer when it's ready
they talk to the knowledge engineer and
that person has a bit okay now how do I
convert that it's one computer can
understand so there's the knowledge base
now what's the database of fats well if
you think about say a doctor okay let's
take an excellent doctor they know all
of these rules so I guess this would
sort of correspond to all of the years
of medical training okay it's like I've
learned when a patient is presenting
with symptoms one two or three and
they've been having it for this long and
so on and so forth then I'll make this
kind of diagnosis that's these rules but
this database of facts is in the next
step in your current situation
okay so when you're trying to make a
specific choice well in the case of the
doctor what's the expert doctor going to
do when you meet you he's trying to
actually diagnose what's wrong
yeah good okay they don't do some
measuring they're going to do some
investigation they're going to ask you
questions in other words they're trying
to gather data about the current
situation they're trying to gather data
now that data is going to go into the
database of facts there the fact that
relates to this particular situation
okay so the knowledge base is relatively
fixed right relatively speaking I mean
obviously if some something changes or
prevailing wisdom is a Jocelyn I attack
let me go back and change the rules but
they by large it stays the same the
database of fats on the other here it's
always checking every new situation is
different so it's not this it's fluid
right always a dusty now just before we
leave off the database in fact not only
does it have facts about the current
situation for example it takes a
temperature observes your ear at first
something like that but it also contains
the knowledge the data about which rules
relate to your situation okay so for
instance let's go back to the GP they've
got all of these things about what kinds
of conditions people have and what
symptoms they caused okay so what they
start asking questions
there are okay you've got you've got a
bit of head cold right they're going to
start to ask questions to do with rules
about your respira system I guess right
and they might not be asking questions
about okay have you got say some kind of
gastrointestinal problem right so all
the rules to do with those the digestive
system will be ignore all the rules to
do with respiratory function and those
kinds of problems they're going to be
reckless and the database of facts will
keep track of which rules are important
which questions are asked all right now
the inference engine will come back to
this guy in a second but very simply all
the inference engine does is it takes
one and two takes your knowledge base it
takes the fact that you know and then it
applies processing to it it's the
problem actually does the job okay if
process is fascism all together in some
kind of consistent way and then it comes
up with a conclusion or good collisions
if there are multiple values if I say so
do you like to think about it right this
is kind of the brain of the expert
system it's the one it's actually doing
the thinking the the processing that's
really all right last bit big
explanation magnetism do you remember
our very very first lesson we looked at
decision support system and we share
decision support systems I'm not there
to replace students right what are they
meant to do instead it is the name okay
so support they meant to help that
little to aid facilitate um provide help
basically right so therefore decision
support systems not that useful to us if
it does all of this stuff spits out a
conclusion and then you you as you would
be using the decision support system you
don't know why right it just made some
recommendation just need some kind of
you do black magic darkening it it just
came up with kujan but I can explain so
what the explanation may be it is a does
is after everything's all done and
dusted in your finish it comes back to
the database of facts and it looks for
two particular things number one it
looks for the rules that were look
investigated and end up factoring into
the final decision if they will be that
the doctor asks for instance say 20
questions but only 15 of them happened
to be related to the final conclusion
any true okay so you'll take those and
we'll take the relevant data and then
you say okay look here's my decision and
here's all the data that supports it
here's my explanation for why this is
the conclusion the result that I arrived
at that make sense you're clarifying any
of those four cases yet quite doing so
it means let's try it
so I say fixed and fluid they're my ways
of trying to the sound there's nice
rhyming couplets for unchanging always
going to be the same more or less right
so these are kind of situations that are
sorry information that is is really
relevant to all situations whereas your
database of facts it's going to change
every time you meet a new person or a
new situation it's going to get wiped
clean and you want to score a new set of
facts and for a new situation
intermission right now I said there was
a kite kind of fifth component okay
which I'm not listening together with
these the third component which is not
quite like the other ones is the user
interface or UI so as a user I want to
be able to interact with this is what
system
perhaps I'm going to have to enter in my
data into a spreadsheet or a form or a
database at some time maybe it has
natural language recognition like Sirius
or do no ever right so the user
interface how do I get data in there is
going to vary from system to system now
the reason why I have included here is
because regardless of what your UI is
doing all of this stuff is essentially
going to be
say it's going to relate in the same way
okay but people often focus on the user
can face the UI because it's what we
experience right so we're like wow Siri
totally different to Google not so much
even though the way you get your
daughter but latitude